oh my god what is that this is a
black-throated monitor lizard
okay where do you want me for this you
could be in a cage of some kind
no you don't have to be in a cage now
this guy's name is darth vader
and he's pretty aptly named because when
he gets upset he starts to hiss and moan
just like
darth vader would but again doesn't moan
he doesn't kiss or mow yeah he does
listen if you saw him r invented the
stampy moans at the end
oh so anyway this guy lives in can i put
my hand out or is that the dumbest
you know what you you can pet him on the
back here but you probably want to keep
your hand away so i'm going up over your
head there you go you can do that i'm
using your skull
as protection you're tall enough so okay
so this yes
so anyways this is a large carnivorous
oh look at him he's looking around like
that felt good he probably people hey
what he probably smells the katy which
is an animal about the size that he
would eat these guys
like to eat small mammals just like that
rodents is there anything i can feed
uh this monitor lizard right now you
know actually nope oh we're not gonna
feed him because
if you get him if you get him if you
feed him he's happy and doesn't attack
he might try to eat me so yeah but yeah
check out those huge claws the tongue
sticking out
people think you get stung by that but
it's actually how they smell it's just
like a snake
they collect scent particles and bring
them back into their mouth and that's
how they kind of you know figure out
what's going on in their environment so
this
not a good candidate for making chums
with another species he'll just kill
anything exactly yeah exactly yeah well
you know predators you know they get a
bad rap because they eat other animals
but they're really important
you know conservation-wise we want to
protect them but yeah if we brought out
one of the little furry guys with this
lizard wouldn't last very long so right
okay yeah sounds like a good segment to
me yeah
where about protecting the wildlife i
think you're not understanding how
television works
if we put these next two species
together they'd fight to the death
but let's not see that all right so our
last species here
is really really cool it's actually the
first time that i've worked with this
particular species it's called an
uh an african southern ground hornbill
and he's taking his time coming in now
we want to come in
i love that he took one peek and he was
like i think not
well come on it's a fun show don't go by
what you've read
so yeah what is this tell me this is a
fascinating looking bird okay so this is
it's a bird right it's called a southern
ground hornbill
okay when you look at an animal like
this you can really see
how birds are descended from dinosaurs
let's see if we can get them over here
now now conan i'm going to give you
do you want a um a piece of fruit or a
piece of a chunk of dead mouse
i would say neither okay i don't have
neither one
is it really just you just put a mouse
in a in a blender well you know
if yeah no you you know you buy them
frozen and it's you know four
carnivorous animals
so anyway these guys are are carnivores
they're actually omnivores but they're
out hunting
on the af in the african savanna and
they're looking they
check out those eyes they're really huge
eyes with really long eyelashes
yeah yeah guys that didn't see the huge
clump of dead mouse coming into that
and then uh what is that thing on the
front of its uh so that helps a
vocalizer social birds you can hear him
making all sorts of little squeaks and
yeah he sounds just like darth vader
[Applause]
[Music]
i walked into that one so so but check
out the bill here you know southern
hornbill is what this uh the the name of
the species that bill is strong enough
that it could actually crack through the
shell of a tortoise
they have fused vertebrae in their neck
and they can pound you which is why
we're not getting any closer to him
because he's pretty close well you know
if you tried to
if you tried to pick him up right now
yeah he could actually like break your
like a bone in your hand if he nailed
you with that well i have very weak
bones so that's what i'm saying
i really do i'm just terribly weak bones
so yeah i mean chunk of dead mouse
that's real i can't get over the chunks
of dead mouse that's freaking me out
right well you know what when you take
care of these animals
in captivity you got to feed them what
is healthy for them and in this case
yeah that's what they eat they eat other
small animals i've noticed you never
come on the show with a mouse so